what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we're picking up with infinity
part I'm sorry infinity War part three
one thing I always found kind of weird
too kind of an aside I saw this one like
a comment section and in the comments
the last video summary was like you
should cover this story that's super
obscure from like 20 years ago and it's
like why though like no one but you
would watch it that's that's weird I
never understood what people do that but
anyway um okay so so here's so here's
the cool thing so initially we pick up
in the aftermath like this explosion
right like this explosion that
supposedly killed all the superheroes of
course they didn't all die this is an
age of Ultron so because of that like
like everybody in this this whole
situation survived but they survived
because of Susan storm now Susan storm
is kind of cool I want to say this is
the point of Marvel Comics when they
were experimenting with the malleus
personality and lord have mercy I really
hope they don't bring that to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe who's you guys who
don't know Susan storm was considered to
be like the Jean Grey of the Fantastic
Four right like for years and years and
years Jean Grey was like worthless I
mean she couldn't do anything
and so like Susan storm was it a lot of
the ways the same way she was just like
the nagging wife so they were trying to
find ways to be for up I like funnily
enough it took Jonathan hate it took it
took like 30 years and Jonathan Hickman
to finally write a story that made her
awesome but one of the things that might
we'll try to do is they experimented
with something called malice where it
was basically like the evil persona of
Susan storm it was not very good they
did other stuff too like they they they
were sure her cleavage and they would
just be like a force symbol in front of
her chest like it was it was just weird
stuff like that but nonetheless like
like when it comes down to it Susan
storm is actually one of the more
powerful people in the superhero
superhero community the other thing I
want to talk about to you and I don't
believe we talked about this in the last
video we may have and I may have
forgotten I want to talk about Thor for
siding so this version of Thor is not
actually Odin's son it's a guy named
Erik Masterson a construction worker but
one of the things that Marvel's done
over the years if they switched out
Odin's son for other people to play the
role of Thor there have been other
people who have played that position
beta ray bill did it for a little while
Erik Masterson did it for a little while
even the Donald Lake personality has
been switched out for other people but
again the idea here and the one the one
big takeaway is that you know of course
all this happens you basically have like
Reed Richards the evil version the evil
doppelganger Reed Richards who's
basically taken by like The Magus and
you know Iron Man and and the you know
doppelganger fanners to kind of peer out
of nowhere but one thing to remember
here is that these are basically three
sets of events three roads all sort of
coalescing into the same locations that
you have Galactus and you have Doctor
Strange and like a handful of others
Silver Surfer Frankie Rey who's this
hair
the time you've got Adam warlock and its
whole infinity watch who are
investigating things and then you've got
earth superheroes who are just now
catching on to the fact that something
is happening and so because of all this
is it is cool and it doesn't work it can
get a little fuzzy at times especially
when you're going through issue by issue
as opposed to like reading it and trade
is one of those things worse a lot
easier to understand what are you
reading the whole thing in trade but
again it does serve as purpose and it
does exactly what it's supposed to do
the other half of this is remember we're
dealing with forces of energy that are
somewhat recognizable but a little bit
ambiguous when it comes to Marvel Comics
the best way to think about powerful
artifacts like the Infinity Gauntlet or
the Cosmic Cube or something like that
it's think of it like a musical note if
I hit like the note of a sharp like
that's the main Marvel Universe if I hit
the note of D sharp that might be the
Ultimate Universe the reason why this
matters is because when your Galactus or
when your Doctor Strange or you're
someone who's trying to home in on
energy signatures you don't necessarily
know what they are because they're not
quote-unquote recognizable you're not
familiar with them because they're not
recognizable introduce a new shows that
you've seen before the Cosmic Cube has
appeared over and over and over again at
Marvel Comics actually like the best way
to explain it but these are other
universe versions of the Cosmic Cube
that they're trying to track down albeit
not really knowing what it is that
they're hunting for and the same thing
goes with like with with Adam warlock
and the Infinity watchin and all these
different guys it's hunting down and
trying to find like this source of these
or these energy emanations and where it
is that they're coming from now
something else that I also want you to
take note of here is the nature of the
Magus because the Magus is like the evil
counterpart to Adam warlock unlike Adam
warlock he's not really grounded in
terms of being like a reasonable person
really it's like every dark desire in
every dark perception and every every
dark aspect of Adam warlock come to bear
and like the form of the Magus and so
he's arrogant he's headstrong he doesn't
believe that he can lose that's the
gamma that he's playing here he believes
he'll never loops like he believes he's
the one that's always on top and he's
always got the upper hand but the
situation proves itself to be true and
that's the nature of things remember
Adam warlock is like a master tactician
he has a you know cosmic awareness he
has all these abilities at his disposal
the Magus has all those as well and so
when you have cosmic awareness and
you're basically aware of what's going
on in the universe all the same time not
to mention like your ability to be a
master tactician then what you basically
do is you treat everyone around here
like your chess pieces and that's what
Magus is doing this is a chess game to
him it's going through it's moving like
The Avengers the x-men or superheroes
it's moving them he
it's moving Galactus and his forces
there it's moving the Infinity watch
there to play this long game for the
purpose of like achieving a particular
goal now the other part of this is
Captain America hits up quasar Wendell
Vaughn now this again goes into the idea
of anthropomorphic things we talked
about in the last video but the long and
short of this is that he basically
traveled out into other dimensions to
try to find help to see if there was
something he could do to basically find
some measure of aid along the way he
finds eternity who's locked in a
catatonic state and this is a pretty
significant deal because someone out
there basically you'll presumably the
Magus by whatever force he's wielding
has the ability to like shut down
eternity which is a pretty significant
amount of power this also comes to bear
when we have like Galactus and his guys
traveling through those you know this
dimensional portal more or less trying
to make their way to the source of this
energy and their ship is destroyed by
the magnets so what we're seeing here is
like this massive amount of energy put
on display by this guy who's going
through like like turn-by-turn and
taking out every single one of these
groups if they get too close and that's
what was going on with Galactus Galactus
and his guys were getting too close to
the source the Magus doesn't mind them
showing up and like seeing him there the
idea is they can't arrive yet they can't
figure out everything that's going on
yet because not all the pieces are in
play and that's really what this is I
mean with Galactus the Magus in terms of
like the external power he has like the
sources of energy he's using in the
cosmic cubes sure he could kill Galactus
by himself not a chance and that's
that's the whole idea it's a like toy
with this whole perception and to keep
all these things going to keep everybody
on the edge of their toes the other
thing I also want you to notice here and
this is really cool a conversation
between Adam warlock and Fanus now the
reason why this matters is because this
sort of back and forth relationship
between the two this goes all the way
back to Infinity Gauntlet
and even before that it goes all the way
back to when jim Starlin is sort of
writing the two characters and then
having them pair up and like the power
of warlock stories for Adam warlock
going forward in the future of Marvel
Comics he will have no it's kind of
weird like a grudging friendship more
like a mutual respect between himself
and Thanos because they've both attained
godhood at some point along the line but
even the worlds they serve are
intriguing you know Adam warlock is an
avatar of life is basically what he has
he's a protector of life he's the Marvel
Comics version of Jesus
Thanos would be like an avatar of death
he worships mistress death he wants to
see things die you know he's a nihilist
he believes that all life is meaningless
but between the two of them because
they're polar opposites and opposites
attract they formed this very strong
bond in terms of like a mutual respect
for each other and that's why you know
jim Starlin
we went forward in the infinity series
with like Adam warlock and Thanos kind
of facing off for being enemies teaming
up all these different things is because
there's this mutual respect that goes on
between the two and that's the funny
thing is because Adam warlock talks
about everything that had gone on the
idea of him having the Infinity Gauntlet
the idea of him basically like showing
up and saving the universe during the
Infinity Gauntlet event and and thousand
responses I mean yeah sure like you
stopped me from using the Infinity
Gauntlet and saved the universe and your
reward was godhood but Adam warlock
willingly gave that up I mean he chose
to go on trial no in truth like they
would have just taken him the loading
table you don't would have just whisked
him away to you know the dimension of
manifestations and would've said like
you're not going anywhere and he was
basically kind of forced to disband the
the Infinity stones after the lady
tribunal had basically decreed they
wouldn't work together anymore but the
fact remains Adam warlock the current
state that he's in in terms of being a
protector of the universe that's a
choice he's not forced into that
position but it's kind of interesting
because when you look at this and you
see Adam warlock in this position where
he's protecting the universe and the
Avengers and the x-men and the Fantastic
Four are nowhere to be found then it's
like okay Here I am yet again saving
their rear ends I third was resting on
their laurels through whatever is
they're doing but again that hits home
at the idea that not all the pieces on
the board know what the others are doing
Adam warlock does not know what the
Earth's superheroes are doing fear of
superheroes don't know what Adam warlock
is doing all they know is that as far as
their own individual pieces of
information are concerned things are
popping off pretty extreme now one thing
I also want you guys to come sort of
keeping the back of your heads for a
second is this is the foundation not as
soon not in terms like the story but
this this set of the set of events in
terms of how they unfold is a foundation
for the Illuminati the Illuminati came
out of the kree-skrull war that's where
that that group formed from but this was
the entire scenario that was taking
place in that event you had all these
different factions and groups who all
had individual pieces of information but
nobody ever bothered to share it it
wasn't until like the very end when
things got dire that it managed to you
know they managed to pull it off but
that was the formation of the Illuminati
the Illuminati were in a situation just
like this like what all the superheroes
and the infinity watch and Galactus are
in and they said well if we'd shared
information we wouldn't run across this
problem so what will form the Illuminati
and that'll be the basis for everything
that's really like how all that kind of
came to fruition and so because this
what you have is you have Scarlet Witch
alongside dr. druid and a handful of
other you know mystics who are there
that are like tracing the sources of
this energy in terms of like what's
what's going on with like cosmic cubes
and so on and so forth now again they
don't know it's cosmic
they just know it's energy out there
somewhere and so of course with the
Mystics basically locating or at least
triangulating this source they kind of
combine their power and wish them all
away to this you know a new dimension
where everybody's supposed to be showing
up where it is that Adam warlock is
hanging out at and that's the whole
basis here is Adam warlock is waiting
for each one of these groups to arrive
in their own turn and make their
presence known and the idea is that if
he timed it correctly they're all going
to arrive at the exact same time and
that's basically what happens the
infinity watch is already here trying to
triangulate this source and then
suddenly they're met by the arrival of
the earth superheroes and were the earth
superheroes look at the situation and
they see
danos their first thought is exactly
what you would expect it to be they
panicked they believed anise is the one
behind it instigating and orchestrating
this whole thing and that's the Magus
plant pip these superheroes against each
other makes them fight one another so
that he can continue on his campaign if
you cannot defeat two opposing enemies
then make them fight each other and then
basically allow the battle to be won
that way
it's a classic rule of engagement make
your enemies fight each other and then
conquer them when they're crippled but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come this explain make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the robb cork do you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]